what would you advise your daughters on
the emotional part of being an artist
sustaining that stability because it is
so rough on bingo that's a great
accomplishment um well I find everything
as an experiment which i think is a
really healthy with all my projects so I
think it sets me up so if it fail I mean
my biggest life lesson the keynote I
gave last night I talked about my
biggest failure in my life which is when
I tried to make a feature film straight
at it UC Berkeley and I totally failed I
learned more from that experience than
anything so to me failing is super
important and to knowing it's okay
knowing it's okay to fail and failing a
lot I mean experiment enough that you're
going to fail and if you frame it as
things as an experiment it's not as hard
to fail because you're framing it that
you don't know what's gonna I mean so
many my films i started here in the end
of here i mean that's the process of a
film for me so i think what i tell my
children when i do tell them is to be
true to themselves and to do what you
love is so important but you know it is
you're my future felt my first feature
film that I finished was connected and
it is my firt it was my eighth film but
though it was my eighth film but the
first film that was a personal phone and
that was very scary it had a very
personal story because I felt the film
required it it was I was exploring what
it means to be connected in the 21st
century and I had made this very we had
a long rough cut but I wasn't exploring
emotional connectedness which I realized
was essential to tell the story why we
need to be on our cell phones and
connecting and where is that from well
it's about our need to connect and where
does that come from but it's really how
we felt connection as a child whether
that was good or bad we are reinforcing
that desire and that's how the human
species survived so I know is I I was
making this feature film and with
written with my father and some of my
co-writers and he got diagnosed with
brain cancer and the film also explores
losing my father which is the such a
profound you know my connection of my
mother and father so important to me so
anyways I I realized that I needed to go
in through that very difficult door into
the film and I realized that hat I was
already done with the foam and realized
it wasn't working which is the worst
feeling that I'm sure so many filmmakers
that are watching can relate to it
you're sitting in the editing room and
you're like this plan isn't working what
is it going to take to make it work and
I realize I have to explore I hear i was
in editing room struggling so much with
losing my father that connection I
needed to go there and it was very scary
and so that was very scary to put myself
so out there in a film but I felt like
if I spoke to my truth that I was going
to speak to some universal truth and I
was so nervous and then the first
screening happen as an amazing response
and the best thing that I didn't imagine
is that I felt so connected to everyone
in the theater because everyone's gone
through something that's what connects
you with other people is the trials of
life and so you know the film has a lot
of humor i'm making the film sounds are
heavy but it definitely goes into some
intense places so that was scary that
was hard and it was scary and but i I'm
so glad I did it now I can't imagine the
film any other way so to my children on
that experience although it was scary
often the things in life that are scary
they're they're going to challenge you
the most and they'll ultimately if they
work be the most rewarding
you